[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le pea paris-saclay mis en place neuf
panneaux pédagogiques soient les actes
du quartier de l'école polytechnique et
le temps de lille ces panneaux ont été
déployés dans le cadre de la stratégie
rse développement durable de le pea et
ils ont été conçus par le bureau
d'études confluence avec l'aide du
comité scientifique
le but de ces panneaux est de
sensibiliser les riverains aux enjeux
écologiques des différents écosystèmes
qui ont fait préservés ou créés dans le
cadre de l'aménagement des hackers ces
panneaux pourront être le support de
balades pédagogiques visant à découvrir
et comprendre le fonctionnement de ces
écosystèmes qui structure le paysage
[Musique]
ces panneaux pédagogiques ils ont été
réalisées à la demande de le paix à
paris saclay ils sont issus du constat
que lors des inventaires qu'on réalise
sur les secteurs les aménagements qui
ont été réalisés dans le cadre des actes
attirent une faune et une flore qui
commence à être relativement
intéressante et diversifiée et en
parallèle c'est aussi des quartiers qui
se peuple qui commence à être fréquenté
pour l'observation pour la balade donc
il y avait un intérêt à faire connaître
l'intérêt de ces milieux et de
comprendre comment est-ce qu'ils ont été
organisées pour les gens qui commencent
à fréquenter régulièrement voit
régulièrement le quartier
on essaye de balayer un petit peu toutes
les thématiques et accompagner une une
déambulation dans ces secteurs naturels
des ac par une continuation par ces
panneaux qui permettent d'accompagner
cette cette balade
ils sont également liés au fait qu' un
certain nombre de naturalistes
observateurs
par exemple ceux qui font partie du
comité scientifique
observe que ces milieux naturels qui ont
besoin de quiétude parce que ces espèces
qui sont relativement sensible des
rangements elles ont besoin d'être
respectés dans leur tranquillité et que
ces espaces parce qu'ils étaient mal
compris et est aussi fréquentée par des
promeneurs par des chiens et peuvent pas
compromettait leurs leur intérêt donc la
volonté
de l'établissement public paris-saclay
c'était d'accompagner par la pédagogie
la découverte de ces milieux pour ça ce
soit des milieux attractif mais qui
préserve aussi lee burke et une pour que
les espèces sauvages qui s'y installent
il reste malgré le développement du
quartier
[Musique]